[Musique]
marc david gagneur est né dans un petit
village du jura abri en 1857 elle est
décédée le 21 mai 1945 à paris
c'est une femme sculpteur dont le nom
d'artiste et si amour siams représentent
les forges de syam donc ça représente la
matière et amour qui représente le
sentiment de ses parents c'est vladimir
gagneur qui est un député radical mais
radicale des années du fin du 19e et sa
mère était une grande féministe et
écrivaine qui s'appelle marie louise
migneault ses deux parents ont eu avec
elle beaucoup de dates h sur des valeurs
de laïcité et de valeurs humanistes leur
marguerite et déjà d'un milieu et
d'intellectuels et donc sa mère encore
organiser des salons déjà et donc elle a
reçu la visite de aussi bien d'écrivains
que deux poètes et d'artistes peintres
et aussi de sculpteurs et parmi eux il
ya antonin masset qui est devenu son
maître et comme ils étaient amis aussi
avec alphonse mouche a donc là elle a
été beaucoup influencé par les drapés
conques ont trouvé par les lignes
courbes qu'on trouvait dans l'art
nouveau
alors marc de gagneur elle avait pour
parrain le président de la république
jules grévy et à ce titre là plus le
fait que son père était député donc il
ya eu beaucoup de commandes publiques
est essentiellement de marianne et les
mariannes comme celle de châteauneuf
c'est une marianne dont les traits sont
celles de l'artiste elle même sur toutes
les marianne on trouvera bien sûr le
liberté égalité fraternité mais on
trouvera aussi d'autres éléments de la
culture des radicaux de l'époque à
savoir
la laïcité une instruction le travail
qui était toujours mise en valeur donc
nous voici à poligny devant la statue du
vigneron
ce qui est particulier c'est que on a
bien l'attrait du vigneron avec le cep
qui est à ses pieds
par contre quand on regarde le reste de
du vigneron
il est protégé par un tablier de
fondeurs et d'une manière très
particulière
le vigneron qu'est ce qu'il fait il
tient un livre nle or il faut savoir que
dans cette période là les ouvriers ils
n'allaient pas à l'école qu'il fallait
comprendre dans cette statue oui on est
un manuel mais on peut aussi apprendre à
lire et et s'instruire au dessus de du
vigneron il y avait autrefois la statue
en portrait de son père de vladimir de
gagneur mais malheureusement il a été
enlevé au printemps 1942 quand ils ont
su qu'à saint claude ont enlevé la
statue de voltaire ici à poligny ils ont
8 démonter la statue et ils l'ont
protégé l'ont mise sous terre et donc
ils ont pu
sauver la statue marguerite gagneur
comme elle n'a pas été à l'académie
puisqu'à l'époque les familles étaient
interdites
donc elle a fait l'école de toulouse qui
est beaucoup plus une école éclectique
donc elle a fait un mélange de réalisme
et de symbolisme dans toutes ses oeuvres
à saint claude
une autre statue de marguerite gagneur
serré statue en hommage à vos carrés
christain alors pourquoi votre carte
estaing parce que à l'époque il y avait
eu jusqu'à la révolution française à
servage des paysans du haut jura
organisé par la cathédrale de saint
claude et donc christ inquiétait avocat
a défendu auprès du tribunal de besançon
pour abolir ce servage
mais il s'est fait aider de voltaire et
c'est pour ça qu'il ya une statue le
volt est un cristal à saint claude qui
malheureusement était retirée en 1942
pour fabriquer des canaux pour les
allemands par décision du gouvernement
de vichy
une cinquantaine d'années plus tard à
l'initiative de la mairie de saint
claude nous avons refait une statue de
voltaire et de christain et cette statue
la a été faite par un artiste donné à
sarajevo qui s'appelle braco
dimitrijevic l'artiste a incorporé des
douilles de char à une extrême dans le
la fonte de la nouvelle statue marié de
gagneur la bouffe couffé des oeuvres
d'art qui défendait des idées humanistes
anti-guerre aussi
et donc elle n'était peut-être pas dans
l'air du temps à l'époque
et puis vers la fin de sa vie elle s'est
retirée peu à peu pour se recentrer sur
elle-même pour une intériorité personnel
donc plus sur la spiritualité
donc ces deux éléments font qu'à mon
avis elle a un peu disparu mais met pas
ses heures
[Musique]